so part of the intent with Whiplash was
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna write something
small and focused and lean and mean and
and and really sort of
simple in a way like hopefully not
simplistic hopefully you can you can
sort of expand it to to a bigger canvas
of ideas but the actual story itself I
wanted to be incredibly clear-cut and
about you know two people with very
clearly defined goals who are just going
like this
um until they realize they have the same
goal basically so it's like the movie
was gonna be about a drummer so you
literally open with a guy drumming and
and the story itself is really about the
drummer's relationship with the teacher
so that's what the first scene had
debate had to introduce the drummer the
teacher and tell you exactly what that
relationship was going to be and then
the rest of the movie could basically
just vary you know Riff on that on that
on that theme
but I like the idea of basically having
an entire movie within the opening scene
of a movie um